En un video anterior hicimos algunos ejemplos de
multiplicación con rejillas y nos dimos cuenta de
que son bastante sencillos: primero hay que
hacer todas las multiplicaciones y después
todas las sumas. En este video intentaremos
entender cómo funciona realmente este método
ya que parece que fuera magia, y para ver el cómo
funciona hagamos de nuevo este problema y también
intentaré explicar lo que hicimos en los problemas
más grandes. Cuando multiplicamos 27 escribimos
el 2 y el 7 justo así, por 48, estamos haciendo
exactamente lo que hicimos en el video anterior.
Dibujamos una rejilla, le dimos una columna al 2 y
una columna al 7, y luego le dimos una fila al 4 y
una fila al 8, y después trazamos unas diagonales.
Como podrás imaginar la clave son las diagonales,
sino no las estaríamos dibujando; dibujemos
nuestras diagonales. Ahora, aquí consideramos
que cada una de estas diagonales es un valor
posicional, por ejemplo, esta diagonal de aquí
es la posición de las unidades, la diagonal que
sigue -usemos un color verde- es la posición
de las decenas, ahora la diagonal que sigue a la
izquierda o arriba, dependiendo de como lo quieras
ver, y usemos este color rosa, puede que hayas
adivinado, va a ser la posición de las centenas,
y finalmente tenemos esta pequeña diagonal de
aquí -y si la ponemos en este color azul claro-,
esta es la posición de los millares. Así que
cuando multiplicamos un dígito por otro sólo
tenemos que ponerlo en el lugar correcto, y verás
a lo que me refiero en un momento. Multiplicamos 7
x 4, bueno, sabemos que 7 x 4 es 28, entonces
escribimos un 2 y un 8 justo así. Pero, ¿qué
hicimos en realidad? La mejor manera de pensarlo
es que este 7 del 27 es un 7 normal, 7 unidades,
¿cierto?; pero este 4 es el 4 en el 48, así que no
son 4 unidades, en realidad es un 40, 4 decenas,
que puede escribirse como 40 + 8 y, por lo tanto,
este 4 en realidad representa 40. Así que aquí no
estamos multiplicando 7 x 4, en realidad estamos
multiplicando 7 x 40, y 7 x 40 no es 28, es 280.
Y, ¿de qué otra forma podemos escribir 280? Bueno,
podemos decir que son 2 centenas más 8 decenas,
y eso es exactamente lo que escribimos aquí,
porque ya hemos mencionado que esta diagonal
de aquí es la diagonal de las decenas y al
multiplicar 7 x 40 pusimos el 8 aquí en la
diagonal de las decenas, así que eso significa
8 decenas, y 7 x 40 tiene 2 centenas, entonces
escribimos un 2 en la diagonal de las centenas y 8
decenas, eso es lo que significan este 2 y este 8,
en realidad escribimos 280. Bien, sigamos. Cuando
multiplicamos 2 x 4 puede ser que digas "Oh, 2 x 4
eso es 8", pero ¿qué estamos haciendo en realidad?
Este es el 2 del 27, en realidad esto es 20 y esto
es 40, así que 20 x 40 es igual a 8 con dos ceros,
es igual a 800, y ¿qué hicimos? Multiplicamos 2 x
4 y decimos "Oh, 2 x 4 es 8", escribimos un 0 y un
8 justo así. Pero observa dónde escribimos el 8;
lo escribimos en la diagonal de las centenas.
Voy a cambiar de color para que lo veas mejor.
Lo escribimos en la diagonal de las centenas, así
que lo escribimos literalmente aunque parezca que
sólo multiplicamos 2 x 4 y dijimos que es 8.
Considerando el lugar en donde lo escribimos,
en realidad lo que hicimos fue 20 x 40
que es igual a 800. Recuerda, esta es la
diagonal de las centenas, todo esto de aquí, y
podemos continuar. Cuando multiplicamos 7 x 8,
recordemos que es 7 unidades, es el 7 del 27, así
que es un 7 habitual, mientras que este 8 de 48
también son 8 unidades, 7 x 8 es 56, escribimos
6 en el lugar de las unidades, 56, y tenemos 5
decenas y 6 unidades, así que son 5 decenas en la
diagonal de las decenas y 6 unidades y me da 56.
Ahora, cuando multiplicamos 2 x 8 observa: no es
sólo 2 x 8, bueno, cuando realizamos el problema
sólo escribimos 16, pero en realidad estamos
multiplicando 20, esto es 20 x 8, 20 x 8 = 160,
o podemos decir que es 1 centena -observa, el 1
está en la diagonal de las centenas- y 6 decenas,
esto es 160. Así que lo que hacemos en esta
multiplicación con rejillas es poner todos los
dígitos en las posiciones correctas: pusimos
el 6 en el lugar de las unidades, pusimos el 6,
después el 5 y el 8 en el lugar de las decenas,
después pusimos el 1, el 8 y el 2 en el lugar de
las centenas, y no pusimos nada, por ahora, en
el lugar de los millares. Ahora que ya acabamos
las multiplicaciones podemos hacer las sumas, sólo
tenemos que seguir sumando, y si algo rebasa hasta
el siguiente valor posicional entonces llevaremos
ese número. Así que tenemos 6 en las unidades,
bueno eso es sólo 6, ahora vamos a las decenas,
¿cuánto es 8 + 5 + 6? 8 + 5 es 13, 13 + 6 es 19,
pero observa, estamos en el lugar de las decenas,
son 19 decenas o podemos decir que son 9 decenas
y 1 centena. Llevamos 1 aquí arriba, lo podemos
ver, llevamos 1 al lugar de las centenas y ahora
sumamos todas las centenas: 100 + 200 + 800 +
100, ¿cuánto es eso? 1200. Así que escribimos 2
en el lugar de las centenas, 1200 es lo mismo que
2 centenas y 1 millar, sólo queda 1 millar en la
diagonal de millares, así que escribimos un 1 aquí
y eso es exactamente lo que hicimos. Ahora bien,
el mismo raciocinio se aplica al problema más
complejo. Podemos etiquetar nuestras posiciones:
esta es la posición de las unidades, y
tiene sentido, cuando multiplicamos 9 x
7 esto es literalmente 9 unidades y 7 unidades,
9 x 7 es 63, 6 decenas y 3 unidades, y este
de aquí es la diagonal de las decenas: tenemos 6
decenas y 3 unidades. Cuando multiplicamos 9 x 80,
recuerda 787 es lo mismo que 7 centenas más 8
decenas más 7 unidades, así que este 9 x 8 es en
realidad 9 x 80, 9 x 80 es 720, entonces tenemos
7 centenas, estamos en el lugar de las centenas,
7 centenas y 20, 2 decenas justo aquí. Y podemos
seguir, este es el lugar de los millares,
aquí tenemos las decenas de millar, este es el
lugar de las centenas de millar y finalmente este
es el lugar de los millones. Así que primero
hicimos todas las multiplicaciones acomodando
todo en el lugar correcto, dependiendo de lo que
realmente representa cada número, en esta entrada
de aquí parece que sólo multiplicamos 4 x 8 y
obtuvimos 32, pero en realidad multiplicamos 400,
este es 400 x 80 y 400 x 80 = 32 y tres ceros, es
igual a 32,000. Y puedes ver que pusimos un 2
aquí, en ¿qué diagonal es esa?, es la diagonal
de los millares; decimos que son 2 millares y 3
decenas de millar, así que 3 decenas de millar y
2 millares es 32,000. Espero que hayas entendido
todo esto. Es divertido hacer multiplicaciones con
rejilla y practicar, pero a veces parece ser algo
extraño y mágico, así que con suerte este video te
haya servido para entender que todo esto es sólo
una forma diferente de llevar un seguimiento de
dónde van las unidades, decenas, centenas y demás,
con la ventaja de que se ve bonito, es claro y
no ocupa mucho espacio; además de que te permite
hacer todas las multiplicaciones primero y luego
cambiar tu cerebro al modo de sumas y acarreo.